we had a student in middle school
message us recently
and they said you know enjoy your videos
would like to get into acting
but they explained what was holding them
back and they
this is how it reads well many reasons
but for the most part it's problems in
school
i stress out a lot about school because
of bullying and i'm still kind of shy
i've been working on getting rid of this
bad habit i guess the shyness
do you have any advice for me i've
stuck it in my mind that after this
school year i will start acting
hmm okay i've got some advice for you
uh what's this fella's name well we're
they're
anonymous oh okay anonymous i have some
advice for you
act if you have a camera and you have
a computer um then you should
find your favorite movies of all time
and find your favorite scenes of all
time from the
your favorite actors of all time and do
those scenes
just do those you don't have to show
them to anybody else but yourself
just do that you can do that all by
yourself without anybody judging you
and you can play you need to sit in
front of the camera
practice every script swear to god you
can find any script you want
online print it out then you can read
the script
you can go over the scene on the tv you
can watch how they're doing it
you can sort of compare and then you can
play with it and you can make it your
own don't try to imitate that person
try to make it who you are because
you're obviously if you're going to do
scarface
you're you're not him you're not al
pacino
you're not a late 30s mid 30s year old
guy from
maybe you're a kid maybe you create your
own backstory for that
where did he come from how did he get
that scar that'd be cool right
then you shoot it on your own camera and
you watch it
and you can think oh my god i suck that
was horrible
and you can laugh about it guess what i
watch stuff that i did before and i'm
like
that moment was horrible but i can do
better
the moments where you suck are just as
important as the moments where you're
good
because they help you make a comparison
value of your own
sense of objective art
so do that play enjoy the process
and then when you watch other people if
you go to an acting class outside your
school
so it's not involved in any of that
social crap that goes on in a high
school
which honestly anybody who's getting
bullied out there you got to realize if
you're in high school
this shit's going to end real soon dude
and real life takes over and nobody
cares
about those people the bullies uh and
actually in the real world
everyone thinks they're dicks so when
someone goes from being a bully in high
school and comes out of high school and
it's still like yo
dude what's up how's it going uh no
one likes them they don't get good jobs
and they fail in life miserably so feel
better about yourself
go find another environment where you
don't have that
bull crap social aspect about your
acting class
and have fun doing that and remember
watching other people is as important as
being on stage yourself i
i still do it if i go to an acting class
i'll watch somebody else and even if
they suck
and sometimes they really suck um
i'll wonder why they suck i don't have
to break it down in my head like
why do i think this person is just not
hitting the comedy or the
dramatic beats like oh because they're
doing this
do i do that i did that one time yeah i
did didn't i
um okay okay
good point good point thank you very
much i'm again talking to myself
but that's as helpful for me as
when i do something really well and
because if you're involved in the
process your goal isn't to be the
world's greatest actor in two seconds
your goal is to enjoy
the moment-to-moment experience of
emoting and feeling the reality of that
story
so when people watch you they feel the
reality so
you can start doing that all by your
lonesome with a camera
of any crappy camera that you have you
can have
they have like imovie although it's the
worst
editing software there is it's on your
frickin phone
um or yeah hot wire car
sell it and buy editing gear i'm kidding
don't do that
but that'll help there you go anonymous
go get em tiger
you